-Oh, I'm sorry.
I didn't order that.
-Courtesy of the gentleman
at the bar.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Whispering ]
[ Laughter ]
-Courtesy of the gentleman
at the table.
[ Laughter ]
A scorpion bowl
with a steak, medium rare,
courtesy of the gentleman
at the bar.
[ Laughter ]
Seafood tower, courtesy of
the gentleman at the table.
[ Applause ]
A pyramid of Ferrero Rocher,
courtesy of the gentleman
at the bar.
Edible arrangement.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Pancakes.
30 hot dogs.
[ Laughter ]
Old coconut with mini hammer.
A bucket of tater tots.
Party sub.
Red M&M.
Astronaut ice cream.
Calcium chews.
Toothpaste with orange juice.
Cheese.
Hibachi shrimp.
Three-tiered wedding cake.
-Could I order --
-I'm sorry, sir.
The kitchen is
completely out of food.
-Well, I guess
it's the check then.
[ Clink ]
[ Laughter ]
-Courtesy of the gentleman
at the window.